MasterCard all that good in the third
quarter so maybe this continues
and Orlando for the turn of oh mo Vagner
pushes Killian Hayes into the crowd
and now in Maryland
ready to Pistons bench
they got to be careful
I'll tell you what there is
they're on a very mineral Orlando Magic
players down on their bench a lot of
them are in this melee Off the Bench all
the way down to the other end
that could end up being some suspensions
for the magic
fortunately for the Pistons it happened
on their bench so it's hard to discern
that
you know who you could possibly say left
the bench none of them left the bench
they were all right there where the
action was
Killian Hayes
he's thrown into the Pistons bench by
Moe Wagner on a hard phone it looked
like Wagner initially
it's apologetic but the damage had been
done
and tempus flared on both sides as you
mentioned the entire Orlando bench made
its way over to the Pistons bench
thankfully no punches for Thrones but
this officiating crew can have to get
together
try to sort it all out
[Applause]
so let's go back to the initial play
goofball his Killian Hayes gonna get
pushed by Wagner mobacher pretty
aggressively Muhammad is going to get
bought by uh Wagner right there in the
back
of you for altercation that did not
dissolve
D I didn't see that in real time I
didn't either
[Applause]
so here it is
[Applause]
hamadu gets Wagner first and Killian
Hayes comes in from the back side
and that's when things got escalated
so the officials are going to take a
look at exactly what we're looking at
see coaches from both sides coming in
trying to separate
I'll tell you this much small Mosley
head coach of the Orlando Magic right in
the middle of it as well trying to get
his guys out of there
if there's an Orlando Magic coach he was
responsible for telling the guys that
are on the bench stay back stay back he
must have got ran over